I will show you tube where I've made a
home walk apparent to the Duster grandma
love will break ooh
[Music]
there's not reasonable
they'll present good enough that one
paper accepted
we will murder important
Promotions Carson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Applause]
[Music]
all right by the way from yesterday show
of all the things that we talked about
comments-section was all about Shang
soon from Mortal Kombat stealing so they
go what got we gain like a dozen mug
love subscribers from that one reference
to okay this is a special show of course
not gay Jared producing them us you as
always
Twitter not gay Jeremy and Ice Crowder
at G Morgan Jr which is over a legal
obligation charge included we have to do
the intro this is a special episode
we've done to support with Patrick Moore
dr. Patrick Moore of course on the
global warming issue PhD in ecology and
now we've had this man on but people
have gotten very mad at us and
threatened to unsubscribe if we have not
had him back for a full you know 45
minutes to an hour threats yeah serious
threats on the internet so you can by
the way right now there's a discount on
a self authoring program if you type in
Crowder 20 percent discount at self
authoring com highly recommend it
professor Jordan Peterson how are you
sir good I think that your people should
underscore T part and okay yes
well yeah thing is we also never want to
be productive in taking a my who could
have been behind the bad I thought it
was suspicious with every single YouTube
commenter made me call him doctor doctor
come on now okay so professor Peterson
obviously you were back on Joe Rogan's
show and you lit the internet ablaze we
wanted to go to some questions from from
Twitter some of those common questions
that we've had let me just kind of get
one to start first up I think a lot of
people to just to set the context are
thrilled that someone like you is out
there because there there are a lot of
commentators are there a few comedians
very few comedians like myself who are
more right-of-center but in the world of
academia and people who have actually
taken a stand against leftist ideology I
should say I don't want to label you
right-wing they're all most people doing
that for you yes but I don't want to
necessarily think of you that way but
you certainly are speaking out against
the really the ideology of progressivism
on campus why haven't you been forced to
resign yet because we have so many
people saying gosh I'm so glad he's out
there but I feel this guy's going to get
the he's going to get them up at Cane
soon
well I think there's a bunch of reasons
I mean first of all the University of
Toronto was actually a pretty good place
you know I mean I've been there for
twenty years more than that and I'm
being treated very well there and um
it's actually all things considered a
rather conservative institution I mean
there there are things going underneath
on underneath the surface that are
that's tilting it in some ways towards
the social justice end of the spectrum
but that's like it is in the real world
I would say it's a pretty noisy minority
yeah now and so so there's that and and
I'm I have been at least reasonably well
regarded at the University like I'm very
popular with the students like my
corners are very popular and I think I'm
very careful about what I say you know
so I have all these all this information
on You Tube hundreds of hours of
lectures that I've given to students and
I mean people have gone over them I
would say with the equivalent of a
fine-tooth comb and not found any it's a
horrible mixed metaphor they've gone
over it with a fine-tooth comb and
haven't found any smoking pistol so yeah
they haven't found any smoking sparrows
from the coma and people mix up their
Karma yeah I live with a french-canadian
mom she does it all the time I can I can
disseminate them but I mean after like
the Duke scandal where a professor was
forced to resign you see it all the time
in the state's people some in some cases
who seem very sensible you know I I just
wonder sometimes if that's a concern
obviously coming I think sometimes
people resigned they're they're older
people sometimes they resign and I think
it's because they just have enough yeah
you know it's quite overwhelming to have
a lot of media attention both positive
and hostile directed towards you and
it's quite unsettling you know and so I
think I have wondered myself the white
people seem to resign so quickly and and
to pull back so quickly I mean yeah it's
partly because it's not that much it's
not that entertaining to be mobbed and I
mean it's it's really becoming a concern
in Canada too because sure we had some
all-out social justice warrior assaults
on on some pretty mainstream famous
journey
in Canada famous and not-so-famous in
the last couple of weeks and I'll focus
to a number of Canadian journalists who
are at the top of their profession I
would say and they're definitely
reporting the tendency to self-censor
and a concern that if they say the wrong
thing in this last round was about
cultural appropriation that they're
going to be targeted by the the internet
mob roughly speaking and and and be hung
out to dry by their colleagues for
example and so well let me know many
times guys because I think a lot of
people aren't operating from necessarily
that's the same kind of knowledge basis
you are explained for people you've
talked a lot about this kind of
classical Marxist theory which is shift
ship shaped it into shape shifted on now
I'm the one with the mixed metaphors its
shape shifted into I mean we say that
it's more so shape shifted into identity
politics what we also say kind of
classical Marxist theory is has shifted
into post-modernism I mean a lot of
people aren't necessarily familiar with
with these terms but you know they're
ubiquitous on campus yeah well there's a
very good book by Stephen R Hicks that I
would recommend I believe it's called
explaining post-modernism it's either
that or understanding post-modernism but
it's definitely Stephen R Hicks and I
would recommend that highly to any of
your viewers especially the first
chapter because it explains how that
shape-shifting process occurred and as
far as I can tell you know by the late
60s early 70s the idea that the West was
going to be overwhelmed by a workers
rebellion and moved in a radically left
direction that was dead in the water and
then of course all the horror stories
started to emerge in an undeniable
fashion about exactly how barbaric both
Mao's China and and Stalin's USSR not
only still and also Lenin how barbaric
those places really were and it became
very intellectually untenable to
maintain a pure Marxist attitude in the
face of both of those things
traumas with the riot rapid rise of
living standards for the working-class
people in Europe and and in West in
general and what happened as far as I
can tell and this happened mostly in
France and under the under the direction
of the post modernists like Jacques
Derrida
and Michel Foucault among others they
just did a sleight of hand and they
exchanged economics for power and the
exchanged economic oppression for
identity politics oppression and just
continued right along with the same yeah
devastating resentful rigid
one-dimensional ideology that that's now
become I would say paramount
particularly in the humanities in the
administration as well or often in the
administration among the student
activists it's the dominant ideology and
it's really a toxic or LPG I think it's
I'm so glad to hear you say that because
we talked about you know before the
election for example Bernie Sanders we
just talked about to see the day where
HuffPost that socialism is cool again
so how all right it's so hot right now
thanks Bernie sales on the actual
headline by the way bell-bottoms you
know nothing of women's fashion you're a
horrible not gay man Jared but it was if
he said socialism with Barack Obama and
I was raised in Quebec basically social
I said when you see grilling me in the N
word it's a racial pejorative and then
that Bernie Sanders I don't know it's
democratic socialism and I was always
saying listen it the two are
inextricably tied this idea of fiscal
like you're saying economic
authoritarianism to a degree you can't
remove that from identity politics and
we had a lot of people during the
election cycles well actually I really
like Bernie on economics but I don't
like that he appease is black lives
matter since the election he's gone full
bore socialism Huffington Post doesn't
even use democratic socialism anymore
it's right out there playing in the open
valuable character space I think a lot
of people have woken up to that and so I
mentioned that you would say yeah that
transition occurred when economically
was no longer viable it made that
transition culturally and it seems like
recently since the left is losing the
culture and you're brilliant on this
they try and shoehorn economics back in
there yeah well I'm not so sure they're
losing you know I mean I don't believe
that the radical leftist types the
professional protesters and so forth are
are represent a very large proportion of
the population but the degree to which
they're organized and effective cannot
be underestimated and they've been and I
think a large part of that is because
the intellectuals let's say who lead the
activist movements have been subsidized
both by private forces and also by
public forces in the universities for
for years and we've raised generations
of of youthful activists who've been
being trained by people who who have the
luxury let's say of doing nothing but
pursuing their their radical the radical
utopian dreams in your spare time and
doing everything they can to push that
forward and and it doesn't take that
many people in this society to have a
very powerful effect if they're well
organized and noisy and effective and
the and with a look at Islamic terrorism
so very very congruent right right well
they look busy you know and the majority
of people generally also stay silent I
think part of the reason I've been left
alone as well and I should highlight
this is that I have received
overwhelming public support and it's not
only from individuals although that's
been a tremendous help all the people
who wrote to the University and in
signed petitions but also the
journalists in Canada swung to my side
pretty quickly in November once they
started looking into what I was saying
and and determining that I wasn't merely
scare mongering and that I wasn't
uninformed that the reason that I was
complaining about or criticizing let's
say some of the legislative moves that
Canada was making I had my facts in
order and I do have my facts in order
and the bill that I was specifically
objecting to bill c16 missing yeah and
still in front of the Senate that's been
interesting too can you explain that to
the American audience who may not be
aware of it now I've told them for a
long time a lot of people aren't you
know there's no Constitution not the
same Constitution in Europe in Canada
freedom of speech doesn't exactly exist
there so that's important regardless of
any other law being put forward to
understand and that's why I listen I'm
always concerned for someone like you in
prosecute comedians being put before
human rights Tribunal's but tell the
American audience who might not be aware
about about Bill c16 well Bill c16 is a
federal bill and it purports to do
nothing but add gender identity and
gender expression to the list of
categories against which she cannot
discriminate in Canada and it also it
also alters the Canadian Criminal Code
to make discrimination and harassment
under those grounds potential
potential grounds for being pursued
under the hate speech provisions and hey
hates these provisions are very
dangerous in my estimation to begin with
the problem comes not so much with the
precise way that the legislation is
worded but in the policy the policies
that have already been developed by
places like the Ontario Human Rights
Commission within which that legislation
will definitely be interpreted and the
federal Justice Department actually said
as much although they took the link off
the website once that it be made public
which was a reprehensible act it's
really a scandalous act in Maya it's
also a stupid act don't think know what
these WikiLeaks people they know people
just go in an Internet time machine it's
like when HuffPo its use Corrections
then remove the article like we can go
back in time yeah no I don't think they
knew that and of course people went back
and down very rapidly and give precise
and out and rescue just which when
you're delorean they're bullshitting
again yeah right right well thank God
for that thank God that the record is
relatively permanent because you know
that's at least one of the advantages of
newspapers is but not so easy to edit
once they're published right when
Annette has about as both an advantage
and a disadvantage anyways I went and
spoke in front of the Canadian Senate
this week and outlined along with a
lawyer who's come to my aid I suppose
but also to the age of Canadians more
generally
detailing out the reasons to assume that
why you might assume that my
interpretation of this particular
legislation is actually accurate rather
than merely bigoted or transphobic as I
you know constantly get referred to even
though I then plenty believe me I've had
plenty of letters from trans people
probably about one a week so far who are
firmly supporting what I'm doing because
they're not very happy that they be made
the newest poster boy or girl or or
whatever they should actually of them
what a week what's done what a week
that's about you know how to population
is half a syringe in your population
that's a thing there aren't that many
transsexual people and to get letters
with that frequency helps me also put
forward my claim that the activists who
purport to speak for this community and
it's certainly not a community by any
stretch should be
nation because how could it be thought
just like a community as a coherent
group of people that are in constant
communication that share an ethos and
like the mere fact that you happen to be
transsexual doesn't automatically make
you identical to all the other Ryan
sexuals who happen to be out there
there's as much variability in that
population as there is in any population
might be sharing a fluids correct
well yes precisely but gee you know one
of the things that was very striking
about the Senate hearings was that the
fact that they had done a very bad job
of sampling the actual population of
people they purport to be speaking for
was immediately evident and when oddly
enough and this is this is how you know
the end of time is coming is that about
300,000 people have watched that Senate
hearing and when 300,000 people watch
something that happens in the Canadian
Senate you know that you know that the
apocalypse is near because ever happens
revelation 17 yes people pay attention
to the Canadian Senate
oh and I looked and behold it's a pail
professor and hell followed with him and
[ __ ] I believe it has that somewhere
in the back um so so let me ask you this
because I think there is a really a sort
of a rule ein where you see with radical
Islamic terrorism although I will say
this I I don't think I think were at the
point now where people are willing to
say all right we don't just have a
problem with Islamic terrorism we have a
problem with the ideology of Islam not
just people who are terrorists we're not
saying all Muslims are terrorists but
the idea of Sharia law the idea of the
way you can treat women and mutilating
girls and Detroit in Detroit this has
changed quite a bit and you've talked
about this you've talked about how
strength is the only sort of language
that they understand that they speak now
Dinesh D'Souza has talked about how you
know certain virtues were not virtues
until modern Christendom for example
mercy it wasn't mercy was considered a
weakness how do we balance obviously as
Christians in Western civilization still
upholding the values the judeo-christian
values well still effectively I hate to
use the word eradicating but certainly
ridding ourselves of people within our
society who want to cause us grave
bodily harm if you need me to restate
the question I can I was trying to fit
it all in there
yeah well that's that's a hell of a
question you know one of the things that
I'm doing in Canada and we'll be doing
more of is I'm going to start a series
of dialogues with moderate Muslims in
Canada and the US and then or X Muslims
but also moderate Muslims the first
person that I planned the interview is
ayaan Hirsi Ali and I'm going to talk to
her on June 1st and then I have a number
of other people who are interested in
pursuing that dialogue and you know I've
heard different opinions on Sharia law
for example certainly her zle is more of
the opinion that the more toxic forms of
totalitarian Sharia law are built right
into Islam as a structure but I've
talked to other people in the Imam in in
Winnipeg for example you see a
reasonable person who's of the opinion
that general democratic laws like the
ones that are characteristic of Canada
and the US can be regarded as Sharia as
long as they hold certain kinds of moral
virtues so you know it's like any
religious structure is unbelievably
complicated and people interpreted in a
very large number of ways and what I'm
hoping is that there's there's grounds
for a real discussion between people who
are of the Islamic faith and people in
the West so that we can find a way
forward that will work out mutually
because the alternative just seems to be
too catastrophic to really to really
contemplate but doing thing for on a
pragmatic level that may be where we're
headed I mean I'm not talking about
moderate Muslims in Canada but you know
you have people you have hundreds of
millions of people who believe in death
for apostasy or blasphemy I mean it's
just what I talked about yesterday you
can correct me if you think I'm wrong
here I really am interested in your
insights and never have we before have
have we had a society that is so
advanced technologically economically as
far as weaponry like we have with
Western civilization who have couch out
and acquiesced to someone to such a
regressive Society I mean usually it
used to be right like oh my gosh we came
up with this new way where we know we
can win wars and you take over one
else's stuff now the only weapon it
seems that these terrorists have is you
see after the Manchester bombing is
guilt and the social justice warrior
sort of postmodernist who appease them
right they feel guilty to to speak out
against Islamic that's really
only weapon they have that's effective
and as you said I worry on that front
they might be winning more than losing
yeah well I mean I don't really know
what to say about that I mean I think
that I think that the more radical end
of the Islamic spectrum is unbelievably
good at manipulating the socialist range
social justice warrior affinity for for
for the more radical ends of Islamic
thought I think they're superb at doing
that there's superb tactician stir and
and it's the question you're asking to
some degree is and I suppose you might
even think about this from a Christian
perspective is that what are the limits
of mercy and tolerance and that's a
really complicated question do you
tolerate intolerance I mean the radical
left would say definitely not because of
course they're willing to shut down
anyone who isn't who they regard as
intolerant and I don't know that to the
ad the answer to that I mean the the
answer that I've been putting forward
generally speaking to the problem of the
inevitability of human conflict
generally speaking is for people to
strengthen themselves as individuals
because I think that as a global
solution it's kind of a low-resolution
solution but you know strong people make
strong families and strong families make
strong communities and strong
communities make a society that's very
difficult to to undermine or overthrow
and I think that's been one of the real
strengths of the West because and it's
partly reflected in the fact that we're
not authoritarian so for example if you
take out the President and even maybe if
you take out the president and all of
the Congress American democracy would
still survive because it's so well
distributed across the entire population
in every sort of institution and even at
a personal level that it's very
difficult to eradicate right over the
North Korea for instance which it's
probably crumble
yes well that's exactly the problem you
know people say well aren't aren't
authoritarian dictatorship sufficient
and the answer to that is well now and
then they're efficient in single
directions but they have a hell of a
time with power transitions right and
that's a major problem whereas in a
democracy you can basically cut off the
hand of the organism which we do on a
regular basis anyway it's almost like
practice and
think it's going without any problem at
all and it's a big deal for that and but
I do think that the fact that that works
is is are they a consequence of having
well individuals who are actually
citizens and those values and in in
their own psyche so to speak and they
also act them out and they create strong
families you mentioned you know I mean
for a long time they were just sort of
poo pooed when when sort of Christian
conservatives and say well listen you
know that there is an attack on the
foundation of society the family and
some of them are obviously
fear-mongering some of them went too far
but it certainly does seem and it seems
there's a weird intersect now where the
Dawkins fan sort of the Sam Harris
listeners the Joe Rogan podcast
listeners this semi former left-wing
atheist have acknowledged there does
seem to be an attack on the fundamental
fabric of society and a big part of that
is with the sort of post modern gender
theory I don't necessarily know how to I
don't know all the big words like you
professor but done and do we think about
the most modernist like they're they
launched an all-out assault on the
fundamental elements of Western
civilization which there's no doubt
about that all you have to read their
websites you know women's studies
websites for example and much of the
humanities is devoted to that because
they truly regard the West as a well I
would say as the equivalent of the of
the of what the Communists used to call
the as the oppressive Burres was a you
know the only reason West is wealthy it
has nothing to do with our structures of
government or anything like that it's
because we rape the planet and every
other civilization and society and
stolen all their wealth and and
distribute it to a very small number of
people and and the thing is rotten right
to the core it's rotten because men
dominated it's rotten because it's
predicated on the idea of logic and the
logos which is a really deep criticism
and and it needs to be brought to its
knees at every level of categorization
perception I mean that's why they're so
that that's why the anti unconscious
bias training has become so popular
because you can actually that gives you
the opportunity at least in theory to
actually re-educate people out of their
actual perceptions not just their
thoughts right and so there's no reason
to underestimate the seriousness of
this assault in my estimation now that
doesn't mean that every person who's a
university student who's sort of
enamored of neo Marxism and
post-modernism is a deadly threat to
Western civilization but they're just
annoying
come on there are fragments there are
fragments of an idea yeah you know you
put enough fragments of an idea together
you get the whole idea acting and that's
exactly what's happening now and you
don't want to underestimate the power of
ideas ideas or ideas move mountains they
move continents and and this is a this
is an idea that that has deep roots in
the humanities and the universities and
it's extraordinarily toxic yeah there
isn't anything about it that I can think
of that's good it's all destructive
strong words strong you wouldn't know
about you when professor Pierson just
said brought to its knees in every level
I had a mild erection anyone else oh
they were so I got a chill like on the
inside
hello it electric copper they don't
understand I apology no I think what
could you have talked a lot of dick
talking to you happen comedy and humor
and everyone's problem I I do think that
you know you talk about this quite a bit
there a lot about obviously other
intellectuals to talk about this how you
said the center of Western civilization
so now we've just talked about Western
civilization sort of versus Marxism and
I think that's really not to simplify it
but I think that is kind of the the the
intellectual battle right now you can
disguise it any way you want it's
basically Western civilization which is
incompatible with marks of the mother
it's cultural Marxism others
post-modernism feminism social justice
warriors and identity politics it all
stems from the same thing we do a long
video on Karl Marx and actually you not
get your even said like I it just seems
like everything now is being
regurgitating going back to yes and line
attack but you said Western civilization
and I don't want to misquote you that at
the center of it is truth that that is
so fundamentally important explained and
spoken truth specifically yes and I
would say also in honesty I mean in the
Christian of those there's a tremendous
emphasis as well on love and and I think
what love is is the essentially is the
if something the truth is nested inside
and I think to love properly means that
you you
Dress someone else in their best
interests you know that what you're
trying to do is to work in their best
interest and your best interest at the
same time and that that's how you're
guided and so you're guided towards the
goods instead of towards destruction but
the most effective tool to use in that
battle so to speak is truth and
specifically the spoken truth and I'm
doing a series on the Bible right now
you know on the psychological
significance of the biblical stories I
did the second lecture last night and
that's been quite interesting uh we've
managed to sellout a 500 seat theater on
promotes lectures which are pretty
bloody remarkable and about two hundred
thousand people have watched the first
one but I'm trying to make a I'm trying
to go back to the to the dream in some
sense that underlies Western
civilization and part of that dream is
that what what brings proper being into
being out of chaos is the spoken truth
yeah and I think that is I believe that
that presupposition is at the
cornerstone of Western civilization and
it with its tremendous emphasis on the
moral obligation of each individual in
each citizen to speak the truth I think
that's a paramount I think that's the
Paramount virtue which it's the virtue
that's given the power to generate chaos
out of order at the beginning of time
essentially and what do you believe that
as a believer like as a Christian
believer or whether you analyze that as
an idea I don't think it in some sense
practically it is it's lesson the
practical differences between those two
things are less important than you might
think because the core issue is whether
or not you believe that the world is
better served by spoken truth or by or
by manipulating and enacting or
instrumentally for your own good and
well then very christian-like as most
people you know look for God so loved
the worlds that we believe in to love it
like you said one of the greatest acts
of love is to speak truth is to be
honest and we actually just talked about
last night on last night's show I mean
give you an analogy a lot of people get
mad when we're critical of Donald Trump
because this is a more right-leaning
show I say listen it comes from the
spirit of I want this guy to do well I
want the country to do well and so it
would be unloving it would be a
disservice of me to him and to
country to not be critical where I feel
it's necessary and honest and it's the
same thing in a marriage sometimes you
never want to speak it out of malice but
truth is is so much more important than
sometimes compassion or validation when
it's not congruent with truth so they're
not mutually exclusive but they aren't
always you know in tandem so while it's
often the case too that it isn't
compassion really that's at stake it's
the desire to avoid conflict in the
moment good point and that is not the
same as compassion because true
compassion hasn't has a lengthier
timeframe you know if you're part of the
reason that you discipline children
which of course often hurts their
feelings and produces immediate conflict
in the environment is part of the reason
that you discipline them it should be
the whole reason really is because you
want to stop them from doing things that
are impulsive ly pleasurable in the
moment but that are going to lead them
into situations social situations in
particular in the means to determine the
long-term that are bad for them if you
don't want your child to be a spoiled
brat with toys because then other kids
will play with him or her and that's a
catastrophe yeah you want to discipline
your children which requires conflict
which requires speaking the truth about
the situation so that they're their path
through life is facilitated over the
longest span of time and the largest
number of situations and you're doing
the same thing in a marriage if you care
for each other is the other spanking
they don't need to go into the details
of your personal life as far as I'm
concerned actually hold on fellas not
gonna do it has a question here he was
he raised his hands well I think what we
hear so much as the combative answer to
that is that there is no such thing as
truth love this will say and liberals
will say that their truth is whatever
you define to be your truth your truth
do you think that's what they say but
the more I think about it I don't know
that they really believe that I don't
know that you can really arrive at that
conclusion if you're thinking through
anything logically I think most people
say you got a father who's gone off the
deep end you want to bring him back the
truth do you really think someone could
argue in that situation that no him
being and drunk and being his family is
his truth you're asking do you think I
guess professor I think what you're
asking is do you think that the left
actually believes that
truth is subjective or do you think they
just use it as an out yes logically they
I think they again to use it whenever
it's convenient for their argument I
mean that I think the radical leftists
and they don't even as far as I can tell
they regard the idea of coherence
logical coherence let's say as part of
the impressive structure that they're
trying to fight against right so so the
idea that they can say one thing at one
moment and another thing at the other
moment is perfectly fine as long as it
serves whatever whatever it is they
think they're serving I mean part of the
criticism of the West is fel logo
centric which is Dara this term is that
the very notion of logic itself is part
of the means by which the West obtain
hegemony and men perpetrate their power
and so you know now do they actually act
that way of well you can because if you
if you if you act incoherently enough
you bump into yourself right you know
down there but then I think that's a
hard thing for them for the more radical
post modernist to admit to because they
don't really like the idea that there's
a real world now there is mysteries
about the real world its nature is
complex beyond our ability to understand
but that doesn't mean that any old
interpretation will do and this is where
this is worth talking about momentarily
I think because I think this is the
logical fallacy that lies at the root of
the problems with post-modernism is that
the post modernists are correct when
they say that any situation or any text
is amenable to an almost unlimited
number of interpretations so for example
even when you're looking at something
that appears to be as simple as a single
room there's an infinite number of
details that you can concentrate on like
the brick wall that's behind you is
unbelievably complicated in its
structure and if there were an artist
trying to paint that like with
photographic realism you find out very
rapidly that although you might perceive
it as brown there's a very large number
of colors in that surface and a
tremendous number of textures and it's
just insanely complicated and so there's
lots of ways to look at the room and
lots of ways to interpret it and so the
postmodern is kind
yeah have taken that idea and then said
well if there's an almost unlimited
number of ways to look at almost
everything including texts and the world
then there's no right way of looking at
it right now okay but that's where the
problem starts as far as I'm concerned
because the first part of that claim is
correct and the second part is incorrect
and the reason it's incorrect is because
because when there's a bunch of reasons
but but one of the reasons is is that
we're constrained by the necessity of
surviving and also by the necessity of
not suffering unduly because people
don't really like to suffer that much
yeah and so when you're interacting when
you're existing as yourself and when
you're interacting with other people
what starts to happen and the world what
starts to happen is the number of
interpretations that are going to serve
any useful purpose including the
cessation of pain starting to come
restricted very very rapidly so for
example if you're married there's a lot
of different ways you can plan your
future but that's limited by the fact
that you have to plan it together and so
that's a huge limitation because you
don't have it be and then of course
you're surrounded by each other's family
and they have to be in on it and then
there's laws regulating it and then but
necessity of actually getting enough to
eat and and maintaining a job and
raising children properly it's so all
these interpretations are constrained by
biological necessity which of course the
post modernists just dispensed with
because they always have enough to eat
bio on you're welcome by the way
that's exactly right you know if if
almost all of your fundamental needs are
met with a minimum of effort you can
easily pretend that they don't exist but
that price is complete rubbish yeah
so you're constrained by the fact that
the world will treat you very harshly if
you apply a careless set of
interpretations to it and then you have
to interpret it in a way that works for
you across time then you have to
interpret it in a way that works for the
people that you're in constant
discussion with and you know it has to
be played out repeatedly across time in
all sorts of different social
circumstances and so you know you could
interpret Hamlet
to to mean that you should you should
kill yourself and everyone around you
well you know that's a possible
interpretation but I wouldn't say that
it's a particularly productive
interpretation and so yeah or little
yeah not a semester may legally either
well that's it is that we there's
another contract well that's it we build
in our bodies contain a lot of
restrictions on what constitutes
acceptable interpretations I mean you
can say well one interpretation of a
red-hot stove is that you can put your
hand on it well you can but if you do
put your hand on if there's going to be
the kinds of consequences that generally
convince you not to do that a second
time and the patriarchy wanted it that
way
not another question well that's the
problem isn't partial constructionist
view point is that if there's this idea
that there is no real constraint on
anything because it's all interpretation
and there's the idea that the social
constraints are merely arbitrary yeah
I'm gonna strew no APHA that the
developmental psychologist Jean Piaget
did a good job of outlining this when he
was talking about children's games so
here is a rule for a child's game
children have to want to play it so and
it's really well really it's a really
important constraint because you know if
you're an unpopular kid and you go on
the playground the first thing you're
going to do is you're going to run
roughshod over what the other kids want
to do you're going to say that it has to
be your game and it has to be played
your way and all that's going to happen
is the kids will close ranks against you
and you'll be an outcast that's what
happens and so even in the world of the
child you're required to act in a manner
that makes you at minimal an acceptable
playmate for other people and that's
really important it is the basis of
adult socialization as well I mean look
what we're doing here is I know it's a
serious conversation but there's a
game-like element to it too you know I
mean if I have to want to do it
voluntarily we can leave it in with a
bit of humor I have to want to do it
voluntarily you have to have an audience
yeah yeah to be technically proficient
enough to manage it I mean there's a lot
of constraints sure and the post
modernists never recognize those as as
real because they don't really recognize
anything is real and the problem is they
try to put in new constraints for
example like you're talking about with
with Bill c16
on everyone else in other words say we
don't believe in these constraints which
happen to be biological historical
logical factual so we're going to create
these constraints basically on you so
that you can't speak in a way that we
don't like not get you you had a
question yeah how would you how did you
come back the argument though that
progressives would say well sometimes a
progress needs to take place in the face
of social or historical constraints
there are times in history BC OXF
slavery or things happen the Middle
Eastern cultures that that would be true
how do you what kind of constraints
navigate the situations and kind of
dissect and weed out okay transgender
issues from say slavery issues what kind
of phenomen guy programs quick question
I mean it for me it's never being the
transgender issue isn't the issue you
know it's the side issue it's like I
don't so with regards to discrimination
let's say for me that's pretty
straightforward issue so you got to look
at the context within the first thing I
should say about that is that people
need to be allowed to discriminate and
on something no one ever says
discrimination is unbelievably important
the best example of that and and we're
going to end we're going to end up in a
fight about this I would say over the
next five years is that people
constantly including the social justice
warrior types reserve the right to
discriminate sexually and that's why
they're so concerned with such things as
sexual harassment sexual assault because
they regard the right to discriminate
sexually as a paramount right but it's
not self-evident from within the
confines of their theory why that should
be the case like why should you be
allowed to hurt someone's feelings if
they want to sleep with you and you
don't want to sleep with them I mean
you're going to do you're going to base
your criteria on health yes on looks YES
on the Admiralty or the what the
admirable qualities of the person
usually on race often on religion you're
going to give all that up yeah and they
not get Jared cages the utilities it's
kind of like a sexual potluck so you
know it don't come off your hand in
there sometimes if you don't have any
more range the casserole is why you have
to take what comes your way but I
we're fortunate enough yes so so the
first thing is is that that we can't
forget that not only is discrimination
necessary but that it's one of the most
basic rights and it's associated with
freedom of association and the most
tangible example of freedom of
association is freedom to choose your
sexual partner and so so that the social
justice warrior types are going to run
afoul of that there they already are in
some sense because the transgendered
people are complaining that they're not
given the same sexual preference as
normative well but but it's like it goes
along with the same logic and you know
in eldest Huxley's brave new world this
is quite interesting is that it was rude
it was a social faux pas to reject
anyone's sexual advance and also to
heaven is anything like a long term
relationship because what you were doing
was discriminating against everyone else
right by preferring one partner and that
is what you're doing like make no
mistake about it that's the ultimate and
discrimination is the ability to say no
to a sexual partner so yeah
Justina polygamy is coming back like I
couldn't come back is that a transition
because you're just talk about this sort
of and Christian culture a very common
question we got so a lot of people asked
and I think it's because we have quite a
few Christian viewers listeners so do
you because you've talked about and
you've given lectures on on Christianity
on sort of the Christ figurehead I guess
more as an archetype the people were
saying do you believe in God or a
spiritual entity in in actuality or do
you believe more so in the the archetype
and the lessons to be owned by
Christianity I'm going to do what I
usually do with that question is I'm
going to refer people to what I've been
saying and if you want an answer to that
I would say that that be worthwhile to
watch the biblical lectures that I'm
doing because I'm trying to answer that
question
it isn't a yes/no question in my
estimation in any useful sense like I
don't want to I don't want to weasel out
of it so I would say that the and then
this is the approach that I'm taking in
these lectures is the first thing is
that I'm going to make as rational
historical and biological a case
possible for the let's call it be
destruction and evolution of these
religious ideas and keep the
metaphysical elements out of it because
I think it's cleaner that way ok but
having said that um having said that I
believe in a significant other ok will
you call them and tell them that I'm
going to be a bit late on that call you
mean in this yeah all right I guess we
just got a time time for him on here so
yeah I guess we do so um you said that
being said that well yeah ok so having
said that have it having decided to take
as rational an approach and as simple as
an approach as possible that's all comes
razor right don't make your explanations
any more complicated than they then they
need to be unwilling to dispense with
the metaphysical element because there's
lots of evidence that people are capable
of experiencing revelatory emotions
let's say for example they're reliably
induced by certain kinds of psychedelics
I talked about that last time yeah I'm
at mushrooms are the best example of
that I would say and it's absolutely
reliable and you can induce those
emotions with brain stimulation and
people about epilepsy often have
religious experiences prior to their
epileptic seizures and that was
characteristic of Dostoevsky and
mystical experiences are reported from
all over the world and have been since
the beginning of time and and there's
one of the things that I found out about
the Christian ideas for example is that
the deeper you dig into them more
profound they become and so although I
think it's safest and most careful to
approach it from as rational a
perspective as possible I'm unwilling to
dispense with the notion that there's a
metaphysical element to existence that
supersedes our comprehension I believe
that and I've had experiences that have
led me to believe that that I I'm not
going to discuss but sure author and it
isn't something that you can casually
eliminate and there's more like I do
believe that one of the things that
Christianity really emphasizes and I
think this is true of many
well-developed religious traditions is
that there's something that that isn't
simply material in the way that we
understand material about consciousness
we don't understand consciousness and
the idea that consciousness is necessary
for
the world to exist is a perfectly
reasonable metaphysical proposition
because it's not easy to understand or
to describe what being would be if there
was no one conscious to experience it
right so if you look at a simple example
go back to Kim's razor had someone I
think was a theology professor explained
it to me say we're three dimensional
beings assume God exists in 12
dimensions
he said that's just weak as three
dimensional beings we can't fully
comprehend it we wouldn't be able to
explain it that was the way I had
explained to me in college so I just
want because I know you know Gerald here
has studied quite extensively in
theology and actually dabbled in
teaching some apologetic specifically
this really is LOM I believe I believe
that professor Pierson is kind of saying
what what I've often said I do believe I
don't hold that back I say if yeah I
believe in God I believe the the
judeo-christian God Christ to be who he
claimed at me but that's never been my
argument I try and argue from as much of
a factual basis as possible particularly
for looking to reach new people right I
believe that that's what he's saying but
Gerald's word did you have a way I
wanted to Kani wanted to confirm is that
kind of what you're saying and into I
think some of the complexities of the
conversations that that you have and
that we all kind of have can I think
make some people go kind of like what
the hell Pat did you say so boiling it
down I think is great and a lot of times
when we talk about those complexities
you're right you can dive into these
religions as much as you want but there
are kind of core doctrines so to speak
to religions that can be fairly simple
on the surface and obviously kind of go
down beyond that so when it comes to
those core doctrines you know Christians
believing in a God believing in Jesus as
his son that he died was buried
resurrected for sins created the
relationship again those are the things
I think when people ask that question
like where do you come down on that I
think the answer they're looking for it
may be a lot more complex than we have
time for but just generally speaking
yeah yeah that seems like something I'm
kind of in line with or no I kind of go
this direction
yeah I think we've got a lot of requests
for that from people and I know you give
lectures but sometimes we'll need it
maybe in the last lecture I gave which
was just last night I started to talk
about what I regard is the psychological
significance of the idea that at the
beginning of time that God
use the word which is identified with
Christ - to call order into existence
out of chaos I was trying to understand
and explain what that means that the
truth of the matter is that it's a
stunningly sophisticated idea and the
fact that it's a stunningly
sophisticated idea means it seems to
indicate to me that there's something to
it it's not some easy superstition like
this correctly the idea that the fact
that John
associated Christ with the Word of God
at the beginning of time is a kind of
conceptual mystery it really is a
conceptual mystery why did that idea
emerge well it isn't just an arbitrary
idea it's a very very deep idea and it
has to do at least in part with the idea
that conscious use of language calls
forth new types of being that and and I
we act as if that's true constantly we
act as if we can shape the world with
our speech and and then that the
presupposition that we can do so I think
is part of is part of what allows people
in the West to return beaut to every
human being some sort of divine
equivalence with God because there's the
idea that you know that we have a spark
of the divine in us and our law is
predicated on that notion and all of our
customs are predicated on that notion
and that seems to have something to do
with our capacity to use language in a
creative and an intelligent way to shape
the direction of the world yeah and and
so I'm unwilling to just dispense with
that idea metaphysically I don't know
what it means in that in the total
scheme of things although one thing I
have learned from studying mythology and
so that's the deep structure of
narrative is but in most mythological
stories that have to do with the nature
of being there's always three elements
there's the formless chaos from which
things emerge there's a structure that
gives rise to the order that emerges out
of that chaos and then there's an active
principle that that structure uses to do
that and that's often represented as the
farther and the Sun and it's always
there it's always there
I'm not willing to dispense with that
notion because it looks to me that
sentient creatures like us do face the
chaotic possibility of being that's
that's the future that we do make
decisions about how it is that we're
going to extract the world out of that
potential that we do use speech as the
means by which that occurs and that that
does determine the direction of the
unfolding of reality and not to tell you
I know you have a timeline on there I
know we're jailed kind of comes from I
think specifically as more sociology as
it relates to other religions and I
think you have argued on the show before
there's the idea of Christ as the person
he claimed he was it's pretty simple and
that there's a strong delineation
between other developed religions as you
put it and it would kind of be the idea
of Christ as compared to other
mythologies would kind of be purposeless
if it were just another one along the
trail yeah I mean he made claims that
have to be dealt with I think is my
point I mean you know we've been talking
a lot about truth and and I think we've
kind of we found ourselves a bit afloat
in society because we really don't have
like what is truth that classical
question you know and where did it come
from and if we don't have that mooring
of truth that has to come from somewhere
then we kind of float around and
everything's okay and so you kind of ask
yourself one well where does that truth
come from is it the judeo-christian god
is that where that comes from and then
talking about truth what Christ claimed
when he claimed to be the son of God
you've always heard this you know
three-part kind of argument he's either
a liar or lunatic or Lord he's a liar
because he knew he wasn't any claim to
be he's a lunatic because he wasn't and
he didn't know he wasn't which would be
kind of a weird way to exist or he's
exactly who he said he was and I think
he did that on purpose CS Lewis is great
about talking about this and saying look
he puts a question to every single one
of us and that's the question that all
of us have to answer one way or the
other it's either the biggest waste of
your time in all of history or it's
absolutely true and and I think those
are my two questions all of you hollered
hopper with underneath my desk I'm sorry
the moment I don't know you're fine but
I think people would have
probably the most profound moment in the
entire conversation to storm on your
daughter I'm sorry it's like my foot I
get but I do I understand your question
so I'm professor Peterson but what would
what would you say that you know someone
kind of you know I guess to sort of
nutshell that Christ said I'm a sword he
comes to divide it there is kind of that
line up on one side I think that's the
question that you know we got a lot on
Twitter and on YouTube people asked he
didn't leave us an out rightfully yeah
well I think it's an open question how
much the world arranges itself in a
different manner around someone who does
everything they can to speak and live
the truth and I think that's the mystery
that's encapsulated in the New Testament
it's like what what how does how does
the full expression of the truth shape
the direction of the cosmos and one of
the things that the New Testament claims
is that it produces a radical
transformation of the nature of reality
and that's a claim that I'm unwilling to
dispense with okay now that doesn't mean
I understand it and I don't understand
it I also do think that there's things
in the New Testament in the record that
we have that are very very difficult to
they're very difficult to understand and
it's difficult to understand why they
haven't been edited out like Christ's
statement about being the way for
example and that no one comes to the
Father except through him and that he
was determined bodied in flesh I mean
those are very strange claims and they
don't sound to me precisely like the
ravings of a lunatic they're not there
they're of a different order you know
that don't necessarily mean that someone
actually said them you know there's a
proof of that in the way that we would
normally consider proof but the the
stories are such that that merely
writing them off as superstitious is not
useful yes right now I agree and I think
that and we do if I wanted to do this
maybe I can do it next time someone did
ask quien in matern can you professor
Peterson can you do a Big Five
personality analysis of Crowder and
share it with the audience maybe we can
do that some next time we can do it
somewhat off air and you can embarrass
me what I do I agree with you there I
think we're coming together with it but
you can't prove every single word that
was
that's written down from the BIOS
necessarily a transcription but the
totality of the historical content the
corroboration is the evidence outside of
just a biblical timeline at a certain
point I think like professor Peterson is
saying you have to determine what you
believe the truth to be and that is one
that not anyone has the answer there's a
certain element of faith there yeah and
I think historically as you look at this
ratcheted up nicely do not try right now
I'm going to say you're right I was
going to say
there's one of the things Center to with
regards to belief no I mean belief isn't
necessarily allegiance to a set of facts
admitted it might even be more
importantly in relationship to Christian
belief that it's the decision about how
to act yeah and there's an idea and this
is I think most well-developed in
Orthodox Christianity is that your moral
duty is to act out the archetypal
pattern of Christ in your life and what
that essentially means is that to tell
the truth in the matter that that that
in the matter that suits and fits you
best your own personal truth and then
paid a price for that in your life and
that that's the appropriate way to be
and so that's what that's in some sense
a different definition of belief and I
think it's a better one because I don't
think that what people say they believe
is the best guide to what they believe I
think the way they act is the best guide
to the way they believe and so then that
would say that would mean that to have
faith in Christ if you considered him
the archetypal perfect human being and
perhaps nothing else but let's just say
I mean that's enough right that's a
pretty good start right that your moral
duty would be to attempt to duplicate
that in the confines of your own life
yeah and that's the actual basis of your
belief and that seems to me to be a
perfectly reasonable proposition and it
also doesn't introduce these other ideas
that are associated in some sense more
with the domain of something like
objective fact it isn't clear to me that
we're exactly in the domain of objective
fact although I know that's a mess I
know it's a mess but no no it's not I
hate because I know you have to go I saw
I saw the message tell you had 15
minutes left I'm gonna get history you
see talk about mimicking the archetype
and that's what we've talked about
that's why there's I believe there's
such a problem with Islam because of
Muhammad in the way that he acted is
very different if everyone acted like
Christ be a little bit we
you might really any guys overly
friendly Mohammed everyone would be
jailed and we can talk about that next
time you come on you think you can do
the big five personality analysis next
time we can share with the audience well
I can tell you a little bit about your
personality I mean you're you're you're
a pretty agreeable person you know you
like people and you're friendly you're
very very extroverted right your
off-the-charts extrovert infrared
highness
yeah you may not notice that welcome
extrovert my suspicion is that your
conscientiousness is probably somewhere
in the medium range because you wouldn't
be a comedian if you were highly
conscientious it's just not it's just
not something like to be an entertainer
isn't something that someone who's
really conscientious can be because the
lifestyle is too unstructured and so um
so that's and in terms of negative
emotion I would suspect probably higher
than average that's neuroticism I would
suspect probably harder than average but
but certainly off the charts for you
know he already put me on the couch okay
well let's do this we'll do it more in
depth next time because I'm interested
whenever I get a little weak personality
test and we can go through it okay that
sounds like fun and the audience will
love to see me out there airy 20%
discount if you enter in Crowder at self
authoring dot-com right trust yes and
that's right yes not CA not like the
rest of those Canadians he's going to
get off the grain professor Peterson
thank you so much for taking the time
sir this has been wonderful and
hopefully people have learned some
truths here today that is it and here's
the music playing we will see you
tomorrow for those who are watching
Tommy Lorenz Amaro's send your questions
out there on YouTube and we'll be
talking about Donald Trump's budget
proposal regarding education that's been
really controversial see you then
[Music]
you
mmm